hi everyone and thank you for being here
so
when working in the public sector my
colleagues and I often encounter a
problem and I'm sure many of you have a
country at some point too
it's we don't get access to the data
meaning there's a lot of data in public
institution and in public administration
but they cannot give it out because of
gdpr regulations
so when I came across synthetic data I
was quite curious and I was also a bit
skeptical
that you could just replace the real
data with the synthetic version and then
go on with your application that you
want to use
but when I got into the topic of
synthetic data I actually discovered
that I could be quite confident that
it's a good solution for quite some
problems there are in public
administration
and we're going to go looking into this
today
so
quick introduction of me I'm Antonia
based in Berlin and I'm working at PD
berate definition hunt as a consultant
and data scientist and basically what we
do is public sector consultancy but the
team I'm on in my unit we're exploring
new technologies and how they can be
valuable for the public
a sector or public administration
actually
and a project I've been working on quite
some time is synthesizing public
administration data in cooperation with
Academia and seeing how you can use this
so today we will be looking at tabular
data I hope you guessed it so I know
image data is quite popular popular
these days like the synthetic images
going around all the time but we're
going to be looking into structured data
and what we can do with this we can look
at a demo exercise and how to generate
and evaluate the data we're going to get
an overview on metrics and evaluation
strategies and I'm going to give you
some learnings from our project
so what is synthetic data you can think
of synthetic data as a version of real
data where you transfer the format
meaning you have the same columns and
features
and you transfer the information
hopefully right so you have the same
distribution of categories
or certain yeah statistical moments that
are exactly well not copied but the same
but you don't transfer any personal
identifiable information so when you
look into the synthetic data and you
look at single records you cannot
pinpoint any information you find there
to a real person in the world
and this is the the huge benefit of
synthetic data because you can actually
share the data
um without it being under gdpr rules not
yet at least and
um this is
um these are the advantages that you can
actually use so often
um you can use
um synthetics data instead of real data
this is only possible to some extent but
it's quite popular in publishing Census
Data you can also use synthetic data to
enhance your initial data if you have
any predictive analysis so if you work
in ml you'll need mostly need like large
data sets and here you can create
synthetic samples especially also
categories that might be not that well
represented in order to enhance your
data basis and then have a better
performance for example and also a huge
application in the public sector is
often creating synthetic data for
software testing because you need
um
a data set that is as realistic as it
can be to test your software on
so a point that people often ask is why
don't you just anonymize the data you
take away the personal information and
then you can kind of use the real one so
in this example you can see quite
illustrative what changes when you when
you do anonymization techniques so this
can be transferred actually to tabular
data but you can see it better in images
so if you take the example if you want
to see what is the distribution of blue
and brown eyes maybe in a population you
can see if you use anonymization
techniques taking out the eyes or
blurring the images these inferences are
quite difficult to do because you
somehow change a bit the format of the
data
and this child you can see here is
actually synthetically generated so it's
not a real child but you can see that
you can use this image in a quite
different way like you can use all the
details that there are and you can maybe
do this inference and you can also
imagine that if you then if you train
you're a model for example on this data
and then you get the real data in it
will perform better if it had this image
from the beginning on
so how do we generate synthetic data
I bet you can guess you use a model to
do this there are some ways also besides
machine learning to generate synthetic
data for example simulation but often a
problem when simulating synthetic data
is that you need a quite High domain
knowledge in order to be able to
formulate this this approximation of the
real data distribution that you want to
have
so we're going to be looking into
generative models today to use it
but how do we actually what does this
actually look like
when we're coding it so here we have an
example data set it's a healthcare data
set and it's about child patients you
can see a summary of the data types
these are just pandas objects so we can
see that you have numeric
variables and you have a categorical
variables and you have even some
missings in the data so we can see here
an ID column with four digits we can
here see the missing values and
otherwise I think it looks pretty basic
and
The Next Step you need to do is you need
to choose a model
and we're going to be using the
synthetic data World package and these
are the options they give us there are
many more out there and there are many
models like catered to different types
of tabular data but these four options
are given in in this package we're going
to be using and you can see Coppola
synthesizer which is a statistical
method we're going to be using the CT
gun which is based on a general
adversarial Network technique which is
also often used in image generation but
you could also use the variation Ultra
encoder or here's some experimental
synthesis between the copula and the gun
so
just shortly on how the Gun Works
um why it learns like the distribution
of the real data it is actually based of
two neural networks and you have the
first Network that gets random noise or
just numbers as input and then learns to
generate
your synthetic samples and then you have
a second Network that is getting the
real data and the synthetic version and
it learns to distinguish them and gives
the feedback back to the generator in
order to make the generator improve on
creating the synthetic samples and this
is actually a quite interesting thing
for gdpr regulation because we're just
using using the generator afterwards
which which is actually not trained on
the real data so the model hasn't seen
the real Data before which is
[Music]
um
quite good for I'm not going to go into
detail in why this is beneficial but I
hope you just trust me
um so looking at the code
um
just a few lines of code and actually
quite simple so we just have some
imports and then we load the data then
we specify some metadata in order to
tell the model what types of columns we
do have in our data set
then we Define the model and train it on
our data
and then we tell the model to sample and
just generate number of rows that we
want to have
so okay let's look into how this looks
like here we have the synthetic version
of it
and I would say it looks quite decent
on the first side at least
so we can see the numbers are
represented we didn't have these like
point zero zero where they're integer
where there's an integer column
we can see here though that the ID
column it's only one integer and our
real data set was like four so maybe we
should do something here
um
but yeah I think it looks pretty good
from the first site
but still I've learned that I shouldn't
trust my first site so we should look
into how to actually evaluate how good
the quality of this data is
and because this is quite important step
we're going to take a step back and just
look at what metrics there are how we
can evaluate what we actually see
and please don't be afraid it's going to
be a bit complex we're just going to
look into a few metrics here
so um
in
um I'm using this paper as a basis I
added some more metrics but basically
what often is done is there are these
three metrics that we're looking at so
we're looking at resemblance analysis
which is just comparing distributions
and statistical features of both beta
data sets and looking how similar they
look
the second thing you can do is looking
at the utility meaning that you're
training a downstream tasks let's say a
regression you're trying to estimate one
variable based on all the other
variables in the data set and then you
see how this algorithm performs trained
on the real data and how it performs
trained on the synthetic data
and you can also do privacy evaluations
looking into different attacks on your
synthetic data and how this data is
actually
um performing or preserving the Privacy
you want to have
digging a bit deeper into the
statistical and resemblance analysis you
can do univariate comparisons
multivariate comparisons dimensional
comparisons looking how they react when
you do Dimension reduction techniques
and data labeling which is essentially
doing what the discriminator already
does meaning I'm just trying to
distinguish between the real and
synthetic versions and you can see how
this performs
and
we're going to be looking into the such
as some statistical tests and into the
visual comparison because it's a quite
intuitive way to see how the quality is
and
um we're also going to be looking a bit
into these overall metrics these metrics
actually only combine like certain
combinations of the upper three
categories in metrics in order to trying
to give you like one metric that you can
specify and tell the data quality on so
we're going to be using this equal
quality score but there are many more as
you can see
so let's Dive Right In well not quite
yet because the second thing that is
really important to do when you want to
create synthetic data is to define a
strategy and to know what you're going
to use your data on before so there are
different metrics that cater to
different needs that you have might have
for your data so here you can for
example see if you want to use it for ML
applications you will want the quality
like the distributional things to be
very well represented if you're using
for software testing you have other
priorities and based on what your
priorities are you can choose like a set
of metrics catering to your needs
so um but let's look into our data that
we had before so if you look at the
overall quality score we can see it's
0.8
1 and
um
one is the best zero is the worst so
it might be performing quite decent
um this overall quality score is made up
of these two metrics these are column
shapes which are just comparing the
universe distribution among the real
column and the synthetic column and then
averaging over all these scores
and we can this it's also taking the
column pair Trends and averaging over
all of these so what it does here is
it's taking two columns in the real data
and calculating the correlation and then
it does the same thing for the synthetic
data and then it's comparing how the
correlations look and then Computing
this correlation similarity score
so already here we can see that it's
using the ID column to compare the
quality which might not really be what
we want because ID is actually not in
numerical
content column I would say so it's just
there to identify the the samples
and now we can look into the visual
inspection we can hear for example see
the distribution how they compare so
we're taking the height column and then
we can see we want the turkeys
um curve kind of to be exactly on the
Dark One
and here we can actually see it's not
that good so
they're quite off there's some
intersection but it's not um how we
maybe want it to be
um we can also use this for categorical
variables here I would say it's quite
decent like it's almost close
the both of the bars
and now we can also look how it looks if
we look at two variables and how they
interact so here we have height and
weight and we can see again that the
synthetic dots are not really aligned
and they don't really look real I would
say
um just records in here you can also do
these for categorical variables then the
plot would be looking a bit more like
this and you would
um kind of want the colors to to match
so we saw that there's quite some
problems and we're going back to our
data set and looking what we can do
So within the sdv package or in general
we can describe the data a bit better so
we can
we have this automatic detection
function that is telling us what data
what data type our columns are and here
we can already for example see that this
ID column is numerical and we actually
want it as and have it as an ID
so what you want to do here we're just
going to tell to update the metadata and
we're telling it it's an ID column so
quite simple
um the second thing we can do is
defining constraints I'm using an
illustrative example
um
here that where you have we have the BMI
column and you can actually calculate it
from height and weight
and so we're going to use this formula
and then you can you have an extra file
where you specify your validation
function
and this form is preset by the package
you define this
a custom constraint class and then when
you train your model you load it and
then
you
give you tell it what columns to use and
then you add this constraints to the
model
then there are quite many more things
you can do so you can tune your model
you can modify the data Transformations
that are done before the model is
trained you can also Anonymous sensitive
data on top
you can also Define distribution of
columns or use conditions when sampling
the last one is very helpful if you want
to if you have like seldom categories
and you want many of those created you
can tell it to
use for example create some with a
specific category in mind
so let's look at how the data is doing
when we're actually improving it I'm
going to use the visual thing because we
can see it way easier so when we add the
metadata we can see the distribution
changes somehow for this column it's a
bit better
when we use constraints it's actually
even more better and remember we're
using constraint actually including this
column
with tuning
we can actually be quite happy with this
I think it's very overlapping
and if you've everything together
um yeah I'm not sure if it's better or
not but looking at the score it tells us
that on average it should be better here
it's at 8.9 and if we tune it's at
8.7 I think yeah so over average over
all the columns it seems to do um better
um so one more thing
um
if you look at the mutual distribution I
think this is really interesting we can
already here also see that it starts to
overlap more and we can kind of get a
feeling for oh um it could actually be
possible to model this kind of mutual
distribution
so
um
coming to the end
I just this is the point I wanted to
talk about a little bit because I love
not wasting but spending many hours on
looking at the data and how to improve
it but there are some issues in the
public sector that you're gonna find and
maybe you also have encountered them
yourself
so we sometimes though cannot work with
the in-house data science team this is
another problem at the moment but in the
long run in public institutions they
should include these
and often we don't have any access
to the data and this is a problem if you
want to create synthetic data out of it
but we are thinking about creating some
dockerized solutions where we actually
only look at the metrics and generate
data
over this not looking at the data but
just taking the data into the docker and
then creating the synthetic data
evaluating it
and for me the most important learning
was that you really need to look into
what the synthetic data is going to be
used for so as I showed you before this
evaluation strategy and the metrics
you're going to be using these are the
most important things that you must have
in mind when you select your generation
strategy and you generate the data
so summing up
um we heard about synthetic data quite
easy to generate less easier is
evaluating it so um we only looked into
this very superficially you should
choose your own strategy and this is the
most important thing I want you to take
with your home
so to notes how to go next
um as the the synthetic data world has
an amazing package amazing documentation
and a very active slack community so in
case you in one like answers to your
questions for your specific use case I
recommend going there
and yeah that's it so thank you for
listening
thank you so much for your talk
um we have a couple of questions
um in 10 minutes so how do you make sure
that the learn model does not plead real
data into the synthetic data set
um yeah that's actually a very good
question
so
um you have some metrics that can
actually control for this so you can
check for duplicates between the real
and the synthetic version
and the the basis for for example for
this gun modeling is that you take
random numbers and the model doesn't
actually see the data so if you would
take the discriminator it has
information from the real data because
it was trained on this real data the
generator just gets feedback and this is
why there shouldn't be any any
information in there
um
they're additionally these privacy
metrics that you can control for
um so how well can you for example
reconstruction attack or something
um but yeah so you would need to check
for it
um yeah that's my answer okay and
Anonymous is asking how did he do your
slides no
quite common question I'm happy I did it
in streamlit so yeah I recommend
checking out it's quite easy to do
how computational expensive is this
method on large data sets that is
hundreds of gigabytes is it possible to
run it on spark
um we've not tried it with spark
um I know that the STV package is
parallelizing and having GPU support so
that's definitely an advantage we were
running a hyper parameter tuning in
parallel so we're using also multiple
gpus we're combining it with Ray but I
haven't tried spark yet so
yeah okay how do you avoid your models
trained on the synthetic data to only
learn the characteristics of the
synthesizer
again
how do you avoid your models trained on
the synthetic data to only learn the
characteristics of the synthesizer
so I guess it's like how do you not let
your models over fit to the synthetic
data generator
um
I'm not sure whether I got the question
right
um so with the overfitting
um not overfitting on the real one but
overfitting on the synthetic data that's
how I would interpret it yeah
um Okay so
um
we're actually not training on the
synthetic data so the only thing I would
think about if you if you're using a
downstream task and you're seeing how it
performs on synthetic and how it
performs on the real data you would use
uh yeah you would use basic machine
learning techniques in order to control
for overfitting I guess
um
then the next one is can the model
guarantee that some conditions still
apply for example diagnosis State before
drug prescription date in the healthcare
example yes
so this was um the part on
custom conditions they're called
custom constraints actually and here you
can specify like the constraint you have
in mind so you can tell it you can the
package supports daytime format columns
and there you can just tell the model
what columns should be before or after
we also often have the use case where
you have like a column which should
always be larger than another one these
kind of things you can tell the model to
do yeah
okay then this one could you elaborate
on synthetic time series generation and
the corresponding difficulties
um
we we were actually not using time
series data but I know that the sdv
package has a model for it I think it's
called HMA one or something
so it's this model is specifically for
using time series data but I know also
that they're in I've read some papers
that also look specifically into Time
series
but I think besides the one model
provided in this package you would
either have to look up another model
yourself or maybe code it yourself
um then another one how about text
column so not categorical but like free
text
um in the SVP
reported I know that their synthetic
um
you can create synthetic data on Text
data but this is not the use case for
this package at least
okay
from Ike to generate a good synthetic
data set you need to have a good
understanding of the original data set
isn't your job done when you created a
good generative model
that's actually a thing that often comes
up I think
the answer I have to this is that often
people that want to work with the
synthetic data they wouldn't know how to
work with the model So in theory yes so
the generator would know the whole
distribution and you could like create
samples out of it but if you for example
publish this for example if you take the
census data set and you have people
wanting to look into it they actually
want to work with the data and see
what's in the data and the data format
it was they know so they might not know
how to work with a trained model and how
to get the information they need out of
this
okay
um then how do you communicate with
stakeholders the fact that the data is
synthetic are there any blockers to the
usage of such data
I think
I think mainly these things often
concern quality and privacy and here of
course you have to tell them what's in
there but I think using these metrics
and quantifying how how large the risk
might be
or quantifying how good the quality
actually is really helps to communicate
this to stakeholders and and often they
actually want to publish their data and
get the data to use because they benefit
from it so they're often very um yeah
open to these arguments
you'll be sharing your slides with us
sure
um I have a GitHub I'm gonna upload them
and I'm gonna put them in the Discord
Channel yeah great
great how does the model deal with
outliers when you
data set for anomaly detection
again the starting of the question how
does the model deal with outliers when
using data sets for anomaly detection
um
so it can handle
[Music]
um
few like it can handle examples of for
example categories that are as bestly
populated so I would say it depends on
the kind of animal detection task you're
looking into
um if you want like
for example if you have a data set on
let's say age and you have an H variable
in there and you have just a few that
are really old and you can create
samples or more samples that have this
specific that are in this age even
though you have few samples in your real
data that you trained on but if you have
like really completely different type of
and like all across all columns for
example this is an outlier it might be
difficult for the model to learn this
characteristics
okay
um then can we get similarly good
results with purely statistical
approaches
um
again it depends I would say
so
um
it depends on what models are out there
and what kind of data you have and
whether there's already a statistical
approach to the kind of modeling you
want to do so if you would have to start
from scratch I can imagine it's going to
take a long time for some problems
especially in physics simulations do
quite well so there you might be good in
looking at simulation that are out there
but I would say for like if you
encounter new data and you don't know
much about how to simulate it
this method would be a go-to first Maybe
okay and then one from Thomas how do you
make sure that oops no it's gonna how to
make sure that you don't lose
characteristics of the data that you
might not know about yet and that are
part of the research question
um well that's in the question actually
so if you know it's part of the research
question you should know that it's it's
like you should look for it in the data
or check for it so you should find a
method that kind of gives you the
information
on this feature and how to evaluate in
the synthetic data yeah
okay thank you so much for answering all
the questions and I think you will be
around for a couple of years hello thank
you very much